[Applause]
[Music]
which time
[Applause]
can I just say guys the first the only
time I know him he admitted admitted
told me about when we were doing a
[ __ ] live stream yeah thousands of
people watching and he was like it's
like that time I walked in on your mom I
was like what you asked for something I
had never told you before and then I was
like well how old were you I was
thinking he's gonna say seven or eight
what'd you say 18.
by the way just looking for the [ __ ]
car keys guys I'm just trying to go to
[ __ ] school 7 30 in the morning I
didn't need that [ __ ] to start my
[ __ ] Monday God damn it yeah you did
no I didn't
[Applause]
well so actually the first time is all
right no wait wait it's a story you told
me that I didn't even know about until I
was informed of it you were young though
yes yeah that time too young to remember
when I was having sex and I felt a
finger touch my ass I'm like
foreign
she's pretty bendy like what the [ __ ]
how'd she get her finger all the way
down there
[Applause]
turns out it was him it was me it was me
it was me
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah yeah it wasn't great yeah
you my wife she buries herself under the
covers and I she just goes get him out
of here
you know when she's under the covers
guess who isn't
[Applause]
it so I'm just trying to talk to him and
I'm like
when I'm naked and he looks just like
the [ __ ] cop he looks me up and down
and he goes
you're funny
[Applause]
and Beth was like is he gone I'm like
yeah he's [ __ ] gone this sews my
heart on
that's right